Hi there, Shankar here. One of the bleak realities of the COVID-19 pandemic is that not every group has been affected equally. Older Americans have suffered more than the young. Residents of some cities and states have faced a higher risk than others. There are also vast racial disparities. There are also vast racial disparities. In Chicago, for example, black people make up 30% of the city's population. They are 56% of the city's COVID-19 deaths. Here in Los Angeles, 16% of deaths are African-American. Only 9% of the population is African-American.
你好，我是尚卡尔。新冠疫情带来的一个严峻现实是，并非每个群体受到的影响都是平等的。美国老年人比年轻人受到的伤害更大。一些城市和州的居民面临的风险比其他地方更高。此外，还存在巨大的种族差异。此外，还存在巨大的种族差异。例如，在芝加哥，黑人占城市人口的30%，但他们占该市新冠死亡人数的56%。在洛杉矶，16%的死亡者是非裔美国人，而该群体仅占总人口的9%。
And this doesn't exist. So I represent that legacy of growing up poor and black in America. And I and many black Americans are at higher risk for COVID. Black Americans are far more likely than white Americans to have contracted the coronavirus or died from COVID-19. Many of the reasons for these disparities reach back to before the pandemic began. There are longstanding inequities in the healthcare system.
而这并不存在。所以我代表了在美国贫穷且身为黑人成长的这种传承。我和许多美国黑人一样，面临更高的新冠感染风险。美国黑人感染新冠病毒或死于新冠肺炎的可能性远高于美国白人。造成这些差异的许多原因可以追溯到疫情开始之前。医疗体系中长期存在着不平等。
In 2019, we talked about a specific source of racial disparities. We also considered an uncomfortable solution. It's a timely topic, and we decided to bring it back today. Here it is. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. There is comfort in the familiar. That's why Marlon Wade likes to head over to his local barber shop, wrist action.
2019年，我们讨论了种族差异的一个具体来源。我们也考虑了一个令人不安的解决方案。这是一个及时的话题，我们决定今天把它带回来。就是这个。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。熟悉的事物会带来舒适感。这就是为什么马龙·韦德喜欢去他当地的理发店“手腕动作”（Wrist Action）。
I just stop in. It's on MacArthur Boulevard in Oakland, California. He doesn't come for a cut. No here, no here. I just wear the ball here. He comes to shoot the breeze. He points to one of the barbers, who's a friend. That's my son's. God, probably. That's one of my old school teammates.
我只是顺便去一下。它位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰的麦克阿瑟大道上。他不是去理发的。不，不是这里，不是这里。我只是剃光头。他是去闲聊的。他指着其中一位理发师，那是他的朋友。那是我的教子，大概吧。那是我的老同学。
Basically, Marlin likes to hang with people who know and understand him. People he grew up with. Some years ago, when Marlin was in the market for a new doctor, people he grew up with. Some years ago, when Marlin was in the market for a new doctor, he looked for that same feeling of connection. I had various choices. I had like, I had over 20, 20 docks of tattoos from. But once stood out, she was like him, black, and like him, a practicing Muslim. She gets me, I get her. We talk about life, we talk about our religion. You know, if something wrong with me, she gonna let me know.
基本上，马龙喜欢和了解他的人在一起。和他一起长大的人。几年前，当马龙在寻找一位新医生时，和他一起长大的人。几年前，当马龙在寻找一位新医生时，他也在寻找那种同样的联系感。我有各种选择。我有超过20位医生可供选择。但有一位脱颖而出，她和他一样是黑人，而且和他一样是虔诚的穆斯林。她懂我，我懂她。我们谈论生活，谈论我们的宗教。你知道，如果我有什么不对劲，她会告诉我的。
It's the kind of trusting relationship Marlon doesn't believe he'd find in a doctor of a different race. I don't think a lot of these doctors relate to people in my skin color. Like when it comes to heart disease, diabetes. Like a lot of these diseases can be researched and medically something done for it, but at the end of the day, my community not getting that service. A variety of studies do suggest that black men in America often receive inferior care compared to white patients. They have the lowest life expectancy of any
这是一种马龙认为在不同种族的医生那里无法找到的信任关系。我不认为很多医生能理解我这种肤色的人。比如心脏病、糖尿病。很多这些疾病是可以研究并进行医学治疗的，但归根结底，我的社区并没有得到那种服务。各种研究确实表明，美国的黑人男性与白人患者相比，往往接受的是劣质护理。他们的预期寿命在所有
major demographic group. Many of the diseases they are dying from are chronic or preventable. Now a growing body of research suggests Marlon Wade might be onto something in his choice of doctor. The black doctors were able to convince more effectively the patients to take more of the preventative services compared to the non-black doctors. This week on Hidden Brain, we considered a simple but controversial way to improve outcomes in medicine, education and other fields. And we ask, what happens when the ideal of a colourblind society runs into hard evidence that you may get better outcomes by not being colourblind? When Owen Garrick was a kid growing up in the South Bronx, he lived across the street
主要人口群体中是最低的。他们死于的许多疾病都是慢性的或可预防的。现在，越来越多的研究表明，马龙·韦德在选择医生方面的直觉可能是对的。与非黑人医生相比，黑人医生能够更有效地劝说患者接受更多的预防性服务。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们探讨了一种简单但有争议的方法，旨在改善医学、教育和其他领域的成果。我们问，当色盲社会的理想与“不采取色盲态度可能会获得更好结果”的硬证据发生冲突时，会发生什么？当欧文·加里克还是个在布朗克斯南区长大的孩子时，他住在街对面
from a bunch of relatives, including his uncle Bobby. So he was the one that you could always hang out with, to the mall, to the store, to some friend's house, you can go swimming with him. He's a guy you can just jump in his car, come back at all hours of the evening, and he was your excuse, right? You know, mom, Uncle Bobby, you know, had me stayin' out all night. But when he was 66 years old, Uncle Bobby found out he was dying of prostate cancer. So he started having bone pain due to the metastasis to his bone, and that brought him in the pain, brought him in. And so then he was diagnosed. He brought him in and so then he was diagnosed.
住着一群亲戚，包括他的鲍比叔叔。所以他总是那个你可以一起出去玩的人，去商场，去商店，去某个朋友家，你可以和他一起去游泳。他是一个你可以直接跳上他的车，在深夜任何时候回来的人，他就是你的借口，对吧？你知道，妈妈，鲍比叔叔让我待在外面整晚。但当他66岁时，鲍比叔叔发现自己患有前列腺癌，生命垂危。所以他开始因为骨转移而感到骨痛，这让他不得不去就医，疼痛让他不得不去。于是他被确诊了。他被带去就医，然后被确诊了。
He probably died a few months after he was diagnosed. In Owen's opinion, it was a preventable death. Prostate cancer is usually slow growing. It's easy to detect. He could still be very much alive and still very much active in his community and with his family, but unfortunately, wouldn't go in for a preventative services. Owen says many of the older men in his family were the same way. They didn't trust doctors, they didn't get preventative care. This is the kind of
他在确诊后几个月就去世了。在欧文看来，这是一场可以预防的死亡。前列腺癌通常生长缓慢。很容易检测出来。他本可以活得好好的，继续活跃在他的社区和家庭中，但不幸的是，他没有去接受预防性服务。欧文说他家里的许多老年男性也是这样。他们不信任医生，不接受预防性护理。这就是那种
story told over and over again in black America. And it's a story reflected in a grim statistic. The average life expectancy of black men is 72 years, about four years shorter than the average for white men. It's not just prostate cancer, it's cardiovascular disease, stroke, it's diabetes. Most of the death is due to preventable or chronic conditions. This is something Owen wants to change. He's a doctor and researcher. He runs bridge clinical research. A company whose mission is to make the medical system walk better for black Americans. Owen is tired of the bad news about black men and health care in America.
在美国黑人社区一遍又一遍讲述的故事。这是一个反映在严峻统计数据中的故事。黑人男性的平均预期寿命为72岁，比白人男性的平均寿命短约四年。这不仅仅是前列腺癌，还有心血管疾病、中风、糖尿病。大多数死亡是由可预防或慢性疾病引起的。这是欧文想要改变的事情。他是一名医生和研究员。他经营着“桥梁临床研究”（Bridge Clinical Research）。这家公司的使命是让医疗系统更好地为美国黑人服务。欧文厌倦了关于美国黑人男性和医疗保健的坏消息。
He's tired of talking about the disparity in health outcomes. What Owen Wands is a fix, a way to get black men, particularly low-income black men, to go to the doctor for preventative care. He wants doctors who will listen to patients and patients who will listen to doctors. So Owen and his fellow researchers, Marcella Alchon and Grant Graziani, designed a field study to try to answer one simple question. Will black men take more preventative care services of their randomly assigned to a black doctor. Is it possible that the race of your physician matters
他厌倦了谈论健康结果的差异。欧文想要的是一个解决方案，一种让黑人男性，特别是低收入黑人男性，去医生那里接受预防性护理的方法。他想要医生能倾听患者，患者能倾听医生。因此，欧文和他的研究同事马塞拉·阿尔琼和格兰特·格拉齐亚尼设计了一项实地研究，试图回答一个简单的问题。如果黑人男性被随机分配给一位黑人医生，他们是否会接受更多的预防性护理服务？你的医生的种族是否重要
in terms of your own health? To find out, Owen and his colleagues rented a medical clinic in Oakland. They recruited 14 black and non-black doctors to staff the clinic during the study. For patients, they turned to flea markets and barbershops in and around the East Bay. Places like wrist action where Mullen Wade likes to hang out. If you go to a black barbershop, you will have all sorts of black men in the barbershop.
就你自己的健康而言？为了找出答案，欧文和他的同事在奥克兰租了一家医疗诊所。他们招募了14名黑人和非黑人医生在研究期间为诊所工作。对于患者，他们转向了东湾及其周边的跳蚤市场和理发店。像“手腕动作”这样马龙·韦德喜欢去的地方。如果你去一家黑人理发店，你会看到各种各样的黑人男性。
How are you doing today? sorts of black men in the barbershop. You'll have folks who like me, you'll have my kids at that barbershop, you'll have folks who didn't graduate from high school and their kids. The first step was asking patrons in these places if they'd answer some basic questions. Some 1300 men agreed to fill out a short survey about their socioeconomic status, health history and level of trust in the medical system. For these efforts, they received cash or a voucher for a free haircut plus a coupon for a free health screening. About half the men showed up at the clinic for that screening.
今天过得怎么样？理发店里各种各样的黑人男性。你会看到像我这样的人，你会看到我的孩子在理发店，你会看到那些没有高中毕业的人和他们的孩子。第一步是询问这些地方的顾客是否愿意回答一些基本问题。大约1300名男性同意填写一份关于他们的社会经济地位、健康史和对医疗系统信任程度的简短调查。作为回报，他们收到了现金或免费理发的代金券，以及一张免费健康筛查的优惠券。大约一半的男性来到诊所进行了筛查。
Before they check up, the clinic staff showed the men a picture of the doctor they'd been randomly assigned. They also asked them to select from a list of preventative care services that they'd be willing to receive. Hightened weight to check body mass index, blood pressure, cholesterol, which is total cholesterol and a diabetes screen which is hemoglobin A1C. At first the man made similar choices. They all accepted, generally, the same level of preventative services. In other words, seeing the photos of the doctors did not change patients' decisions about what services to accept. Typically, the men would choose some of the services, but not all.
在检查之前，诊所工作人员向这些男性展示了他们被随机分配的医生的照片。他们还要求他们从一份预防性护理服务清单中选择他们愿意接受的项目。身高体重以检查身体质量指数、血压、胆固醇（即总胆固醇）以及糖尿病筛查（即血红蛋白A1C）。起初，这些男性的选择相似。他们都普遍接受了相同水平的预防性服务。换句话说，看到医生的照片并没有改变患者对接受哪些服务的决定。通常，这些男性会选择一些服务，但不是全部。
They might agree to get their body mass index and blood pressure checked, but forego the tests for diabetes and cholesterol that come with a needle stick. But what happened next changed their choices. The doctor then comes in and says, okay, Mr. Smith, you've only selected these three, you know, you've only selected heightened weight and blood pressure, we really recommend that you take all five, because they're all recommended, they're all good for your health. As I said, some of the black patients were randomized to receive this advice from a black doctor,
他们可能同意检查身体质量指数和血压，但放弃需要针刺的糖尿病和胆固醇测试。但接下来发生的事情改变了他们的选择。医生走进来，说：“好吧，史密斯先生，你只选择了这三项，你知道，你只选择了身高体重和血压，我们真的建议你接受全部五项，因为它们都是推荐的，对你的健康都有好处。”正如我所说，一些黑人患者被随机分配接受来自黑人医生的建议，
some from a non-black doctor. Did the race of the physician affect what patients did? The black doctors were able to convince more effectively the patients to take race of the physician affect what patients did? The black doctors were able to convince more effectively the patients to take more of the preventative services. And not just by a little, by a lot. The black doctors were about 20% more successful than non-black doctors at getting patients to have their blood pressure and body mass measured.
一些来自非黑人医生。医生的种族是否影响了患者的行为？黑人医生能够更有效地劝说患者接受更多的预防性服务。不仅仅是一点点，而是很多。在让患者测量血压和身体质量方面，黑人医生比非黑人医生成功率高出约20%。
They were even more effective at persuading their patients to have invasive tests. For diabetes and the flu shot, the black doctors were about 50% more successful than non-black doctors. And then came the cholesterol results. There was a 72% difference in the ability of the black doctor to recommend and have the black male patient take cholesterol screening compared to the non-black doctor. 72% Now the real life implications of these results might be significant. High cholesterol, for instance, can lead to heart attacks, strokes.
他们在说服患者进行侵入性检查方面甚至更有效。对于糖尿病和流感疫苗，黑人医生比非黑人医生成功率高出约50%。然后是胆固醇检查结果。黑人医生推荐并让黑人男性患者接受胆固醇筛查的能力与非黑人医生相比，存在72%的差异。72%。现在，这些结果的现实意义可能是重大的。例如，高胆固醇会导致心脏病发作和中风。
What if black patients in the real world responded to their physicians like the counterparts in the study? Owen Garrick says the gap in the United States between blacks and whites and cardiovascular disease outcomes might shrink by nearly 20%. That could be 20% of the people living to see their grandkids graduate from college in high school, right? That's how I think about it.
如果现实世界中的黑人患者像研究中的对应者那样对他们的医生做出反应会怎样？欧文·加里克说，美国黑人和白人在心血管疾病结果方面的差距可能会缩小近20%。那可能是20%的人能活着看到他们的孙辈从大学和高中毕业，对吧？我是这样想的。
These results suggest they might be an easy, low-cost way to save the lives of black men. Owen and his colleagues wanted to understand what was going on. Why were the black doctors so much more effective? The researchers didn't think prejudice was at play because the patients rated all the physicians black and non-black, as equally good. But then they discovered a clue. It was in the notes the doctors had written about their patients. We found that the black doctors actually wrote more notes compared to the non-black doctors
这些结果表明，这可能是一种简单、低成本的挽救黑人男性生命的方法。欧文和他的同事想了解发生了什么。为什么黑人医生如此有效？研究人员认为这与偏见无关，因为患者对所有医生（黑人和非黑人）的评价同样好。但随后他们发现了一个线索。它在医生关于患者的笔记中。我们发现，黑人医生实际上比非黑人医生写了更多的笔记
about their patients. And often those notes talked about their non-health care issues. A wedding is coming up. Will the war is repeat as NBA champions? Like, so non-medical issues. The black doctors and black patients were connecting as human beings. They were talking about family, sports, life.
关于他们的患者。而且这些笔记经常谈论他们的非医疗问题。婚礼快到了。勇士队会蝉联NBA冠军吗？等等，也就是非医疗问题。黑人医生和黑人患者作为人类在建立联系。他们在谈论家庭、体育、生活。
It's the kind of chitchat that says, I know where you're coming from. I hear you. Marlon Wade from the Barbershop made the very same point about his doctor. She gets me, I get hurt. We talk about life, we talk about our religion. You know, if something wrong with me, she gonna let me know. Owen's research is part of a growing body of work that suggests matching patients and
这是一种闲聊，意思是：我知道你的处境。我听到了。理发店的马龙·韦德对他的医生也表达了同样的观点。她懂我，我懂她。我们谈论生活，谈论我们的宗教。你知道，如果我有什么不对劲，她会告诉我的。欧文的研究是越来越多的研究工作的一部分，这些研究表明，根据种族匹配患者和
doctors by race can make a difference in health outcomes. In another study, researchers found that Florida patients assigned to physicians of their own race were 13% less likely to die while in the hospital. These results were driven almost entirely by black patients matched with black physicians. The research raises difficult questions about our medical system, our society, and our biases. The clearest takeaway from the research is that warm and empathetic communication matters. Owen Garag believes that doctors might be taught to bridge some of the differences he observed in his study. Because if communication is the mechanism, you can train or you should be able to train
医生可以在健康结果上产生差异。在另一项研究中，研究人员发现，被分配给同一种族医生的佛罗里达州患者在医院死亡的可能性降低了13%。这些结果几乎完全是由与黑人医生匹配的黑人患者驱动的。这项研究提出了关于我们的医疗系统、我们的社会和我们的偏见等棘手问题。从研究中得出的最明确的结论是，温暖和共情的沟通很重要。欧文·加里克认为，医生可以被教导去弥合他在研究中观察到的一些差异。因为如果沟通是机制，你可以训练，或者你应该能够训练
non-black doctors to more effectively communicate with their patients. There is a more daunting takeaway. If you want better outcomes in health care, especially among the most vulnerable patients, having a more diverse pool of physicians is crucial. Owen says what he wants is for patients to have a choice. If they want to see a black doctor, they can choose one. But right now that's often not possible. 4% of physicians of black, blacks represent 13% of the US population, so not a representation. It's important to note that choice is not just something blacks might prefer. In a follow-up survey, Owen and his team found that both black and white respondents indicated a same race preference.
非黑人医生更有效地与他们的患者沟通。还有一个更令人望而生畏的结论。如果你想要更好的医疗结果，特别是在最脆弱的患者群体中，拥有更多样化的医生群体至关重要。欧文说他想要的是让患者有选择权。如果他们想看黑人医生，他们可以选择。但目前这通常是不可能的。4%的医生是黑人，而黑人占美国人口的13%，所以这并不代表人口比例。值得注意的是，选择不仅仅是黑人可能更倾向的事情。在后续调查中，欧文和他的团队发现，黑人和白人受访者都表示了同一种族偏好。
65% of black surveyed said a black doctor would better understand their concerns. 70% of whites said a white doctor would better understand them. There is a third implication of Owen's research, and it feels radioactive. Given the results, I asked him, should hospitals and medical centers match patients and doctors by race, particularly when it comes to black men? Owen challenged the notion that this needed to be a radioactive idea. Ferturneities and sororities self-select by gender. You could argue that that's segregation. I wouldn't argue that that's segregation, but you know someone might, you know, a pessimist might,
65%的受访黑人表示，黑人医生会更好地理解他们的担忧。70%的白人表示，白人医生会更好地理解他们。欧文的研究还有第三个含义，它感觉具有放射性。鉴于这些结果，我问他，医院和医疗中心是否应该根据种族匹配患者和医生，特别是在黑人男性方面？欧文挑战了这必须是一个放射性想法的观念。兄弟会和姐妹会按性别自我选择。你可以争辩说那是种族隔离。我不会争辩说那是种族隔离，但你知道有人可能会，你知道，悲观主义者可能会，
and I think in the pessimists of the world might argue that recommending black physicians for black patients is segregation. I don't see it that way. Still, Owen acknowledges he would be uncomfortable with the idea that hospitals would deliberately steer black patients to black doctors and white patients to white doctors. After all, we struggled as a nation for decades to overcome segregation. How would patients react if they were told when they showed up at a clinic, you're black, so we're sending you to the black doctor? There is some tension here, right? Because there are two values, I think, that are in conflict with one another here. I mean, there is one value that basically says, you know, we should all essentially treat one another the same. We should all get along well. We should all, you know,
我认为世界上的悲观主义者可能会争辩说，为黑人患者推荐黑人医生是种族隔离。我不这么看。尽管如此，欧文承认，如果医院故意将黑人患者引导至黑人医生，将白人患者引导至白人医生，他会感到不安。毕竟，作为一个国家，我们几十年来一直在努力克服种族隔离。如果患者在诊所出现时被告知“你是黑人，所以我们把你送到黑人医生那里”，他们会作何反应？这里存在一些张力，对吧？因为我认为这里有两种价值观在冲突。我的意思是，有一种价值观基本上说，你知道，我们本质上都应该平等对待彼此。我们都应该相处融洽。我们都应该，你知道，
as Dr. King would say, look at each other's character and abilities and not the color of our skin or our gender. I mean, so that is an ideal. And the other ideal is we should trust the data and we should trust the evidence and we should follow where the evidence leads and it feels like those two values following the evidence and the data and following this norm that we have about how we'd like our society to be, these two values are in conflict. Right, and they're partly in conflict because we don't live in an ideal world. And some might argue, skeptics of the world might argue that we profess to live in an ideal world,
正如马丁·路德·金博士所说，看彼此的品格和能力，而不是肤色或性别。我的意思是，这是一个理想。而另一个理想是，我们应该相信数据，我们应该相信证据，我们应该遵循证据指引的方向，感觉就像这两种价值观——遵循证据和数据，以及遵循我们关于希望社会成为什么样子的规范——这两种价值观在冲突。是的，它们部分冲突是因为我们并不生活在一个理想的世界中。有些人可能会争辩，世界上的怀疑论者可能会争辩说，我们声称生活在一个理想的世界中，
and we know absolutely the world is not ideal. So given that, given the cards your adult, the life you live, the world we exist in, how do you best, in our case, accomplish improved health outcomes for all populations and specifically in our research study, the black male population. And this issue of the race of the doctor seems to work. And it isn't just in medicine. When we come back, the results of matching people by their identities from education, to retail, to banking.
而我们绝对知道世界并不理想。鉴于此，鉴于你所处的环境、你过的生活、我们所处的世界，你如何最好地——在我们的案例中——实现所有人群的健康结果改善，特别是在我们的研究中，黑人男性群体。而医生种族这个问题似乎确实有效。而且这不仅仅是在医学领域。当我们回来时，我们将探讨按身份匹配人们的结果，从教育到零售，再到银行业。
In 1985, researchers in Tennessee launched a massive experiment to see if class sizes affected learning. There was plenty of anecdotal evidence at the time suggesting that kids did better and smaller classes, but there was no hard data to prove it. Project STAR changed that. More than 11,000 students from kindergarten through third grade were randomly assigned to one of three class size groups. Researchers track their performance over time. The experiment is now considered one of the most important education studies ever conducted. It
1985年，田纳西州的研究人员发起了一项大规模实验，以观察班级规模是否影响学习。当时有大量的轶事证据表明，孩子们在小班中表现更好，但没有确凿的数据来证明这一点。STAR项目改变了这一点。超过11,000名从幼儿园到三年级的学生被随机分配到三个班级规模组之一。研究人员跟踪了他们的表现。该实验现在被认为是进行过的最重要的教育研究之一。它
showed that smaller class sizes led to substantial improvements in early learning, especially for minority students. In the decades since, researchers have also come to realize the random placement of kids in project star could be used to study something else. If you are randomizing by class size, something else. If you are randomizing by class size, you are also randomizing by teacher race. This is Constance Lindsay. She is an education professor at the University of North Carolina in Chapel Hill. She said this insight led to a new research question. Do children who have a teacher of the same race do better than children who don't. Education Research at Thomas D was the first to analyze the project star data in this new way.
表明较小的班级规模导致了早期学习的实质性改善，特别是对于少数族裔学生。在随后的几十年里，研究人员也开始意识到，STAR项目中对孩子的随机分配可以用来研究其他事情。如果你按班级规模进行随机化，你也在按教师种族进行随机化。这是康斯坦斯·林赛。她是北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校的教育学教授。她说这个见解引出了一个新的研究问题。拥有同一种族老师的孩子是否比没有的孩子表现更好？教育研究员托马斯·迪是第一个以这种新方式分析STAR项目数据的人。
Did students do better if they were matched with the teacher of the same race? In 2004, he published his findings. Constance says they were striking. If you're a black student and you have a black teacher on average you're going to have a higher test score than a black student who has a white teacher. The findings weren't just specific to black kids. They also held true for white students. Both black and white kids did better on math and reading achievement tests if they had a teacher of the same race. Thomas D. Warrid that his results might cause people to call for increased racial segregation
如果学生与同一种族的老师匹配，他们是否表现更好？2004年，他发表了他的研究结果。康斯坦斯说它们令人震惊。如果你是一名黑人学生，并且你有一位黑人老师，平均而言，你的考试成绩会比有一位白人老师的黑人学生更高。这些发现不仅仅针对黑人孩子。它们对白人学生也适用。如果黑人和白人孩子有同一种族的老师，他们在数学和阅读成绩测试中都表现得更好。托马斯·迪担心他的结果可能会导致人们呼吁增加种族隔离
in schools. He felt that would be a mistake. He first noted that his results only apply to how kids were doing during the foyer experiment. The results did not predict achievement over longer time periods. Second, he felt the best takeaway would be more study. He urged researchers to continue exploring why race dynamics matter in the classroom. 14 years later, Constance Lindsay and her colleagues did just that. Basically what we did is we said, let's use the fact that we can follow the students over many, many years and see what happens to them in terms of high school dropout,
在学校里。他觉得那将是一个错误。他首先指出，他的结果仅适用于孩子们在四年实验期间的表现。这些结果并不能预测更长时期内的成就。其次，他认为最好的结论是进行更多的研究。他敦促研究人员继续探索为什么种族动态在课堂上很重要。14年后，康斯坦斯·林赛和她的同事们正是这样做的。基本上我们所做的是，我们说，让我们利用我们可以跟踪学生多年这一事实，看看他们在高中辍学方面发生了什么，
whether they take a college entrance exam, and then whether they enroll in college. In other words, they tried to answer the open question Thomas D had raised. Do black children who were randomly assigned to black teachers perform better over the long term? What they found is those early interactions had a lasting effect. Black students in our sample who were matched to a black teacher were less likely to drop out of high school more likely to sit for college interest exam, so think, you know, SAT, ACT, and then more likely to enroll in college.
他们是否参加大学入学考试，然后是否进入大学。换句话说，他们试图回答托马斯·迪提出的悬而未决的问题。被随机分配给黑人老师的黑人孩子在长期内表现更好吗？他们发现的是，那些早期的互动产生了持久的影响。我们样本中与黑人老师匹配的黑人学生辍学率更低，参加大学入学考试（想想SAT、ACT）的可能性更高，然后进入大学的可能性也更高。
The success of Black students increased with every year they were matched with Black teachers. Black students who spent more time with Black teachers did better than Black students who spent less time. These results could have huge implications. They suggest that race matching might be one way to get more at-risk black kids to stay in school and go on to higher education. Of course, Tennessee is just one state and researchers wanted to make sure they weren't looking at a one-state phenomenon. So they turned to North Carolina. This state has a huge public school
黑人学生的成功随着他们与黑人老师匹配的每一年而增加。与黑人老师相处时间更长的黑人学生比相处时间更短的黑人学生表现更好。这些结果可能产生巨大的影响。它们表明，种族匹配可能是让更多处于危险中的黑人孩子留在学校并继续接受高等教育的一种方法。当然，田纳西州只是一个州，研究人员想确保他们看到的不是一个州现象。所以他们转向了北卡罗来纳州。这个州有一个庞大的公立学校
database. It contains all kinds of information about students, including their demographics, the classes they've taken, and the race of various teachers over the years. Again, the researchers looked at kids in elementary school and then tracked them over time. Now these kids weren't randomly matched, like they were in Tennessee, but still they had exposure to black and non-black teachers. Constance says the results told the same story. Black kids who'd had black teachers were less likely to drop out of high school. And then when you finish high school in North Carolina, there's a survey you fill out that says, I will attend college, I will not attend college. It's basically like an intent to attend college measure. And we find that more black students who are a batch to black teachers report wanting
数据库。它包含关于学生的各种信息，包括他们的人口统计数据、他们修过的课程以及多年来各位老师的种族。同样，研究人员观察了小学里的孩子，然后随着时间的推移跟踪他们。现在这些孩子不像在田纳西州那样被随机匹配，但他们仍然接触到了黑人和非黑人老师。康斯坦斯说结果讲述了同样的故事。有过黑人老师的黑人孩子高中辍学的可能性更低。然后当你从北卡罗来纳州的高中毕业时，有一份调查问卷，上面写着“我将上大学，我不会上大学”。这基本上是一个“上大学意向”的衡量标准。我们发现，更多与黑人老师匹配的黑人学生报告说想要
to attend college. Students who benefited the most from having a black teacher were those most at risk of dropping out low income black boys. The North Carolina data showed that these boys were 39% less likely to drop out of high school if they had a black teacher in elementary school. 39% What constants and her colleagues were seeing in education is what Owen Garrick saw in medicine. Race matters. Now we don't know why these black teachers were making such a difference in the lives of their black students,
上大学。从拥有黑人老师中受益最大的是那些最容易辍学的学生——低收入黑人男孩。北卡罗来纳州的数据显示，如果这些男孩在小学有黑人老师，他们高中辍学的可能性降低了39%。39%。康斯坦斯和她的同事在教育领域看到的情况正是欧文·加里克在医学领域看到的。种族很重要。现在我们不知道为什么这些黑人老师在他们黑人学生的生活中产生了如此大的差异，
but the researchers think a variety of forces might be at work. One could be implicit bias. Teachers may hold unconscious prejudices that negatively affect black students. That prevent them from, you know, maybe identifying kids for things like gifted programs or enacting harsher discipline punishments. Constance says black teachers also service powerful role models for black students. The presence of, you know, a college educated adult
但研究人员认为多种力量可能在起作用。一种可能是隐性偏见。老师可能持有无意识的偏见，对黑人学生产生负面影响。这阻止了他们，你知道，可能识别出孩子的天赋项目，或者实施更严厉的纪律惩罚。康斯坦斯说，黑人老师也作为黑人学生的强大榜样。拥有，你知道，一位受过大学教育的成年人
in your life makes a difference. And then there's what's called cultural competence. Which is that teachers are able to read behavior better if you sort of share, you know, if you have cultural things that you share in common. This seems especially true in the area of discipline. In another research project, Constans and our colleagues have found that one reason black boys sometimes get into trouble at school is because of something researchers call Willful Defiance. Willful Defiance is I get into an argument with the teacher and you know, I maybe I talk back or something along those lines
在你的生活中会产生差异。还有所谓的文化能力。也就是说，如果你分享，你知道，如果你有共同的文化事物，老师能够更好地解读行为。这在纪律领域似乎尤其如此。在另一个研究项目中，康斯坦斯和她的同事发现，黑人男孩有时在学校惹麻烦的一个原因是研究人员所说的“故意反抗”。故意反抗就是我和老师争论，你知道，我可能顶嘴或类似的事情
and then you have to go to the principal's office. And so what do you see with Willful Defiance? So we see that the drops in Willful Defiance are huge when you have a black teacher. But just as there's a shortage of black doctors in America, there's also a shortage of black teachers. Nationwide, teachers in elementary and secondary schools are overwhelmingly white, despite growing racial diversity among students. So for example, in the North Carolina data, both in the long-term study and in the discipline study that I have, over 50% of the black students never have a black teacher.
然后你必须去校长办公室。那么你在“故意反抗”中看到了什么？我们看到，当你有一位黑人老师时，故意反抗的下降幅度是巨大的。但正如美国缺乏黑人医生一样，也缺乏黑人老师。在全国范围内，小学和中学的老师绝大多数是白人，尽管学生中的种族多样性在增加。例如，在北卡罗来纳州的数据中，无论是在长期研究还是在我拥有的纪律研究中，超过50%的黑人学生从未有过黑人老师。
On a very personal level, Constance knows well the lasting impression a black teacher can leave on students. Because my grandmother was a teacher here in DC Public Schools for a very long time. Constance describes her as a warm, demander. This is someone who is sort of hold you accountable for the things that you should be doing, but does it in a warm fashion. Her name was May Wilson. May Wilson. Well, dealing with her, she was stirring, kept an order, she kept an orderly class from. She was the boss, you know.
在非常个人的层面上，康斯坦斯非常清楚黑人老师能给学生留下的持久印象。因为我的祖母在华盛顿特区的公立学校当了很长时间的老师。康斯坦斯形容她是一位“温暖的严师”。这是一个会因为你应该做的事情而让你负责，但以温暖的方式去做的人。她的名字叫梅·威尔逊。梅·威尔逊。嗯，和她打交道，她很严格，保持秩序，她保持了一个有序的班级。她是老板，你知道。
This is Donald Williams. He's in his late 60s and has lived nearly all his life in Washington, DC. In the early 1970s, Donald was a student at a school that has educated generations of African-American students, Dunbar High School. This is where May Wilson taught. From an old yearbook, Don points to his younger self, a star football player at Dunbar. Here I was blocking, there I was running with the football, there I was running with the football, there I got tackles. Most of Don's memories from high school revolve around football, except for that home room teacher, May Wilson, whom he's never forgotten.
这是唐纳德·威廉姆斯。他60多岁，几乎一生都住在华盛顿特区。在20世纪70年代初，唐纳德是一所教育了数代非裔美国学生的学校——邓巴高中的学生。这就是梅·威尔逊教书的地方。从一本旧年鉴中，唐指着年轻时的自己，邓巴高中的明星足球运动员。这里我在阻挡，那里我在带着足球奔跑，那里我在带着足球奔跑，那里我被擒抱了。唐对高中的大部分记忆都围绕着足球，除了那位班主任梅·威尔逊，他从未忘记过她。
She's like five, five, four, but her demeanor was bigger than that. She didn't take a lot of nonsense. You knew it. You knew it. She's like your mother away from home, but she didn't take any stuff. She didn't cut any corners. Dawn says there was something about May Wilson that made you pay attention. Maybe it was the Taylor Scott suit she wore or her air of authority. She always looked business. She always looked business.
她大概五英尺四英寸，但她的风度比那更大。她不容忍废话。你知道的。你知道的。她就像你离家在外的母亲，但她不吃那一套。她不走捷径。唐说梅·威尔逊身上有一种让你注意的东西。也许是她穿的定制西装，或者是她的权威感。她看起来总是很职业。她看起来总是很职业。
She never came in a nightclub dress or something like that. She always looked professional. So that's another message that you saw in her that she was sticking, she stick to the rules of being on time, doing things that you need to do, not being proud of controlling yourself in public. Her lessons ultimately stuck and became life lessons for dawn. I asked him if it made a difference to him, that May Wilson was black. He told me the question was a no-brainer. Yes, of course it made a difference. It's a black kid. You can relate better when you see someone in the position that you're in.
她从来没有穿过夜店的裙子之类的东西。她看起来总是很专业。所以这是你在她身上看到的另一个信息，她坚持准时、做你需要做的事情、在公共场合控制自己等规则。她的教诲最终留了下来，成为了唐的人生课程。我问他，梅·威尔逊是黑人对他是否有影响。他告诉我这个问题不用想。是的，当然有影响。作为一个黑人孩子。当你看到和你处于同样位置的人时，你可以更好地产生共鸣。
Because if you're not black, you can't understand what I'm saying. You can say it because it's the right thing. Go on, it's, oh you don't. You couldn't possibly know because you're not black. the right thing. Don, it's, oh you don't. You couldn't possibly know because you're not black. Don has the same feeling about his football coaches. He says shared identity often led to trust. Like I said, a kid needs to see someone who's been there. It's easy for you to talk it when you got it. It's easy for a rich man to tell you to save your money. He got money. How can a rich man tell a poor man what's going on, what life is about? It's got to be someone that knows the avenues to go to the someone that's black, that's been through it.
因为如果你不是黑人，你无法理解我在说什么。你可以说出来，因为那是正确的事情。唐，那是，哦，你不。你不可能知道，因为你不是黑人。那是正确的事情。唐对他的足球教练也有同样的感觉。他说共同的身份往往会导致信任。就像我说的，孩子需要看到一个曾经经历过这些的人。当你拥有它时，你很容易谈论它。富人很容易告诉你存钱。他有钱。富人怎么能告诉穷人发生了什么，生活是什么？必须是一个知道该走什么路的人，一个黑人，一个经历过这些的人。
You know, you got to, and then you know that's his ticket, that's his motivation there to show you was how it can be done. Giving students the feeling that they are understood by their teachers who can say this is a bad idea but if you zoom out putting this idea into practice runs into all sorts of problems related to history, politics, and optics. I asked Constance Lindsay about this. Let's say you're the principal of a school and you have one black teacher in second grade and you have, let's say, 15 black students spread across five sections of second grade.
你知道，你必须，然后你知道那是他的入场券，那是他的动力，向你展示它是如何完成的。给学生一种被老师理解的感觉，他们可以说这是一个坏主意，但如果你缩小范围，将这个想法付诸实践会遇到与历史、政治和观感相关的各种问题。我问了康斯坦斯·林赛这个问题。假设你是学校的校长，二年级有一位黑人老师，假设有15名黑人学生分布在二年级的五个班级中。
Would you assign all those 15 students to the black teacher? I probably would not do that. If I had students that in that particular set of 15 that were particularly disadvantaged, I might. I might also explore ways in which teachers could co-teach so that all of those 15 students would have the opportunity to interact with that teacher, but I definitely wouldn't advocate sort of segregating them into one class. Why not? That's what your data show works. That is what the data show works.
你会把所有那15名学生都分配给那位黑人老师吗？我可能不会那样做。如果在那15名学生中，我有特别处于弱势的学生，我可能会。我也可能会探索老师可以共同教学的方法，这样那15名学生都有机会与那位老师互动，但我绝对不会主张把他们隔离在一个班级里。为什么不呢？你的数据显示那样做有效。数据确实显示那样做有效。
But I think we agreed that segregation is bad. But I think this is what makes the paper really, really tricky, which is it's actually suggesting that something that we thought was a good thing might have an outcome that is not such a good thing. That's right. That's right. So I guess if you held a gun to my head and you said I had to pick between segregating students and making sure that students had a black teacher, I would pick that they had a black teacher. So you actually would put the students in the same class there? If you
但我认为我们同意种族隔离是不好的。但我认为这正是让这篇论文非常、非常棘手的地方，因为它实际上是在暗示，我们认为是一件好事的事情可能会产生一个不太好的结果。没错。没错。所以我猜，如果有人拿枪指着我的头，说我必须在隔离学生和确保学生有黑人老师之间做出选择，我会选择让他们有黑人老师。所以你实际上会把学生放在同一个班级里？如果你
said I had to. No, I guess what I'm asking you is not so much whether I have to, but you know, if you looked at the data and said that you are improving the odds of students by 10, 15, maybe 20 percent, and you did not do that thing that could improve their odds by 10, 15, 20 percent, I mean, that is immoral. You could say that. You could say that. I mean, if I were a parent of a black boy and there was one black male teacher in the school, I would go tell the principal to assign my child to him. There is some evidence that race matching effects we see in medicine and education also show up in other spheres.
说我必须。不，我想我问你的不是我是否必须，而是，你知道，如果你看了数据，说你通过那样做将学生的几率提高了10%、15%，也许20%，而你没有做那件可以提高他们10%、15%、20%几率的事情，我的意思是，那是不道德的。你可以那样说。你可以那样说。我的意思是，如果我是黑人男孩的家长，学校里有一位黑人男老师，我会去告诉校长把我的孩子分配给他。有一些证据表明，我们在医学和教育中看到的种族匹配效应也出现在其他领域。
At Temple University, Derek Avery and his colleagues found that customers at a retail store who interacted with sales agents of the same race had higher levels of satisfaction. This was especially true in areas where racial minorities were a larger share of the customer base. Columbia University's Raymond Fisman found in a study conducted in India that ethnic and religious matching between bankers and customers increased the likelihood of loans being repaid. It also lowered the cost of loans because banks perceived there was a lower risk in lending money. Other workers observed that gender can act in similar ways to racial or religious identification.
在天普大学，德里克·艾弗里和他的同事发现，在零售店与同一种族销售代理互动的顾客满意度更高。在少数族裔占客户群较大比例的地区，情况尤其如此。哥伦比亚大学的雷蒙德·菲斯曼在印度进行的一项研究中发现，银行家和客户之间的种族和宗教匹配增加了贷款被偿还的可能性。它还降低了贷款成本，因为银行认为贷款风险较低。其他研究人员观察到，性别可以以类似于种族或宗教认同的方式发挥作用。
Brad Greenwood at the University of Minnesota found that more women in Florida Survived a heart attack when their doctor was a woman rather than a man At the University of Massachusetts social psychologist Nilanjana Daskup that has found that female students in calculus classes were more engaged in the subject when they had a female professor were more engaged in the subject when they had a female professor rather than a male professor. Just having a female professor ends up making women feel they'll do better in the class, so making them feel more confident, making them feel that they care more about math than when the same course material, same exam, same syllabus, is taught by a male professor. course material, same exam, same syllabus, is taught by a male professor. This is important because calculus is a gateway class to degrees and careers in math and science where women are currently underrepresented.
明尼苏达大学的布拉德·格林伍德发现，在佛罗里达州，当医生是女性而不是男性时，更多的女性心脏病发作后幸存下来。在马萨诸塞大学，社会心理学家尼兰贾纳·达斯古普塔发现，微积分课上的女学生在有女教授时对这门学科更投入，而不是男教授。仅仅有一位女教授最终让女性觉得她们在课堂上会表现得更好，从而让她们感到更自信，让她们觉得她们比在同样的课程材料、同样的考试、同样的教学大纲由男教授教授时更关心数学。这很重要，因为微积分是通往数学和科学学位及职业的门户课程，而女性目前在这些领域代表性不足。
There are three lessons from all these examples. The first is that we really need doctors and teachers and loan officers and store clerks from different races and different backgrounds. It can have tangible and measurable outcomes. The second lesson is that if we want to be understood by people who are different from us in some way, it's going to take work. You can't just assume that your job begins and ends with teaching a course or diagnosing the patient.
所有这些例子中有三个教训。第一个是我们确实需要来自不同种族和不同背景的医生、老师、贷款官员和店员。它可以产生切实且可衡量的结果。第二个教训是，如果我们想被与我们不同的人理解，那需要付出努力。你不能仅仅假设你的工作始于并终于教授一门课程或诊断一名患者。
You have to make a connection with the human being across from you. The final lesson has to do with the seemingly contradictory effects of diversity. In an earlier episode of Hidden Brain, the Edge Effect, we talked about how diversity boosts creativity and innovation. By contrast, here we've seen how connecting with people who I like us can produce better outcomes. One explanation for this contradiction lies in what you are trying to achieve. You want novelty and creativity? Those flourish from bringing together different perspectives. But if you want trust and communication, those come easier when we have things in common. This week's episode was produced by Jenny Schmidt and Path Shah. It was edited by Tara Boyle and Raina Cohen. Our team includes Laura Quarelle, Thomas Liu,
你必须与你对面的人建立联系。最后一课与多样性看似矛盾的影响有关。在《隐藏的大脑》之前的一集《边缘效应》中，我们讨论了多样性如何促进创造力和创新。相比之下，在这里我们看到了与我们相似的人建立联系如何能产生更好的结果。这种矛盾的一种解释在于你试图实现的目标。你想要新奇和创造力吗？这些源于汇集不同的观点。但如果你想要信任和沟通，当我们有共同点时，这些更容易实现。本周的节目由珍妮·施密特和帕斯·沙制作。由塔拉·博伊尔和雷娜·科恩编辑。我们的团队包括劳拉·夸雷尔、托马斯·刘，
Kat Shuknecht and Lushik Waba. Our unsung hero this week is Jeff Rogers. Jeff runs two of our sister NPR shows, The Ted Radio Hour and How I Built This. He played an early role in helping get hidden brain off the ground. He's also the kind of person you want to have when things are changing quickly around you. Jeff can be coach, friend, and taskmaster. He has an uncanny ability to stay calm, which is why when many people say they have a problem, they also say,
凯特·舒克内希特和卢希克·瓦巴。我们本周的无名英雄是杰夫·罗杰斯。杰夫负责我们两个NPR姊妹节目，《TED广播时间》和《我是如何建立这个的》。他在帮助《隐藏的大脑》起步方面发挥了早期作用。他也是那种当你周围情况迅速变化时，你希望在身边的人。杰夫可以是教练、朋友和任务监督者。他有一种保持冷静的不可思议的能力，这就是为什么当许多人说他们有问题时，他们也会说，
I'm sure Jeff can help with that. For more hidden brain, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter. If this episode reminded you of someone who is connected in a meaningful way with you, whether that's in the classroom, the doctor's office, or at work, please share this episode with that person. Tell them the impact they had on your life. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我相信杰夫能帮上忙。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到我们。如果这一集让你想起了与你有意义联系的人，无论是在教室、医生办公室还是工作中，请与那个人分享这一集。告诉他们他们对你生活的影响。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。目前这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。